ahora que tenemos una idea general sobre
la mecánica de todo esto quiero discutir
por qué los diferentes actores hacen lo
que hacen y cómo podrían beneficiarse o
perjudicarse durante este ciclo y
también por qué es tan difícil deshacer
este ciclo y que los actores salgan de
este al final del vídeo anterior hablé
sobre cómo había más efectivo en los
bolsillos de los estadounidenses porque
básicamente la deuda se abarata así que
pueden gastar más y tener menos
impuestos y por lo tanto tener más
dinero para comprar más productos chinos
aunque también hay más dinero para
gastar en ellos mismos quizá a comprar
sus propias casas o pagar servicios
mutuamente por lo que se estimula la
economía en general el que la deuda sea
barata y haya bajas tasas de interés
provocan que se estimule la economía
normalmente cuando se estimula la
economía con todos estos factores se
corre el riesgo de aumentar la inflación
recuerden que la inflación de precios
básicamente es el precio de todos sus
bienes pero noten que cada vez compramos
más bienes muy baratos y la tasa
interés es baja así que el crecimiento
superficial de los gastos promedio de
los consumidores estadounidenses da la
apariencia de ser más positivo y la
inflación se mantiene baja por lo que
hay dinero para comprar servicios
mutuamente ahora pensemos en el por qué
cada uno de los actores quieren hacer
esto desde la perspectiva de china
ustedes son china y ustedes comienzan
como un país totalmente comunista hace
30 años comienzan a tener reformas en el
mercado y desean entrar al mundo en
desarrollo durante el final de la década
de los 70 y principios de la década de
los 80 ustedes no tienen una base
industrial como para competir con los
alemanes o los estadounidenses o los
japoneses en sus mismos términos
así que una ventaja de crecimiento con
base en la exportación es que cuando
apenas se comienza a desarrollar es que
se tiene una sociedad menos desarrollada
industrialmente con el crecimiento
basado en la exportación se estimula la
inversión en la construcción de fábricas
hacer o construir cosas que se vendan en
el mundo desarrollado y al mantener la
moneda baja de manera artificial y
permítanme aclarar algo con el
intercambio libre estándar el costo de
la mano de obra se volvería más barato
en lugares como china o india en donde
el estándar de vida es más bajo por lo
que en un intercambio comercial sin
manipular se tendrán productos que
tendrán que moverse al extranjero pero
si se hace muchísimo más barato para que
los fabricantes hagan sus negocios en
china se acelerará la inversión de la
producción en china
voy a escribirlo de este modo moneda
artificialmente devaluada
y esto también sucedió con japón después
de la segunda guerra mundial y hasta
cierto punto los eeuu querían que
ocurriera esto ya que querían que japón
se entretejieron con ellos y que
tuvieran éxito pues ya se vio lo que
pasó con alemania después de la primera
guerra mundial que quedó tan mal
económicamente que estuvo expuesta a que
un personaje como hitler llegara al
poder así que se aprendió la lección
nunca es bueno que un país no pueda
recuperarse económicamente por lo que
esto hasta cierto punto se promovía en
japon así pues la moneda artificialmente
devaluada provoca la exportación barata
lo que estimula la inversión en la
producción local más producción en casa
y con local me refiero a dentro del país
subdesarrollado ya sea china o japón y
este aumento de producción local implica
mayor inversión si se produce más en
china se va a tener que invertir más
localmente lo que literalmente significa
más empleos y hasta cierto punto mayor
capital para la gente de china
conforme esto se vuelve más eficiente y
más competitivo y conforme se supera la
curva de desarrollo en toda una serie de
industrias cuando tu gente se vuelve lo
suficientemente desarrollada se tendrá
localmente capital suficiente como para
que una parte de lo que se produce
regrese a su propia gente se pueden
vender estos bienes y productos a la
gente local para aumentar su estándar de
vida al principio se construyen
lavadoras y refrigeradores para los eeuu
lo que genera empleos para los chinos y
esto eventualmente hará que ellos tengan
el dinero suficiente para comprar estos
productos
estos mismos refrigeradores y lavadoras
aumentando el estándar de vida todo esto
genera una base manufacturera y un
mercado local desde el punto de vista
chino esto es bueno sin ambigüedad
genera la base manufacturera y mercado
de consumo doméstico lo que significa
que la gente en china una vez que tienen
trabajo y capital podrán comprar sus
propios productos
dónde está el aspecto negativo aquí
pueden imaginarse que si ustedes son el
país desarrollado que están comprando
estos productos serán baratos al inicio
pero después serán artificialmente
baratos pero ustedes perderán la base de
manufactura local visto desde eeuu se
pierde la base de manufactura y es muy
claro que esto ha pasado tanto en japón
como en otros países algunas personas
ven esto como algo bueno ya que dicen
bueno pues ya estamos mucho más allá de
la curva de desarrollo y no deberíamos
enfocarnos en la manufactura ya que esto
normalmente va a aquellos países que
ofrecen los precios más baratos que
nosotros deberíamos enfocarnos en
generar conocimiento como en la
industria farmacéutica o en las
tecnologías de información otra razón
por la cual esto es atractivo para eeuu
es que disminuye los costos para los
consumidores estadounidenses esto es
algo superficialmente bueno y perder la
base manufacturera pues no lo es tanto
si usted no fue de esas personas que
perdieron su trabajo en la fábrica para
la gran mayoría de los estadounidenses
esto es algo bueno es más barato comprar
ropa para
es más barato comprar autos o
refrigeradores o aires acondicionados
ahora el problema es el cuándo y cómo
termina esto porque todo este ciclo que
vimos y que luce muy bien para china al
menos en teoría se devalúa su moneda sus
productos son más baratos hay más
inversiones locales y más capital que
eventualmente se apunta al propio país y
entonces ya se tiene como un país
desarrollado todo esto parece tener
sentido pero es más fácil decirlo que
hacerlo particularmente no es nada
sencillo lograr que el mercado local se
vuelva tan consumidor como el mercado
extranjero de los países desarrollados
otro problema es que todo el tiempo
recuerden aquí se están acumulando toda
esta enorme cantidad de dólares que se
usan para prestárselos al gobierno de
eeuu que esencialmente es prestarlo al
pueblo de eeuu y en el momento que deje
de ocurrir esto y no hablamos de
deshacer todo el ciclo hablamos
solamente de dejar de comprar dólares la
moneda se va a inflar y estos miles de
millones de dólares en bienes que se han
acumulado comenzarán a perder su valor
ya que el yuan comenzará a aumentar
shuválov y esto pasa si solamente se
deja de comprar dólares si alguna vez se
intenta deshacer este ciclo
completamente en el momento en el que
dejen de vender esto bajar aún más el
valor del dólar o de los bonos del
tesoro así que en todo momento que ellos
han mantenido devaluada su moneda han
estado comprando estos dólares y estos
bienes con el solo hecho de tratar de
deshacer lo harán que se desploma el
valor de todos los bienes que han
comprado esta es una situación muy
difícil para los chinos ya que no pueden
salir de ella y también es una situación
difícil para los estadounidenses ya que
en el momento en que se intercambien
libremente las monedas y que se terminen
las manipulaciones de los gobiernos para
mantener fijo este intercambio de
divisas
los chinos comenzarán a vender sus bonos
y letras del tesoro habrá menos demanda
de éstos aumentarán las tasas de interés
a largo plazo en eeuu
y esto ocasionará que los préstamos sean
más difíciles las tasas de las tarjetas
de crédito aumentarán y la economía
general de eeuu se vendrá abajo de hecho
la actual recesión se debe a que es más
difícil pedir prestado se depende tanto
de la deuda barata que si esta deuda ya
no es tan barata todo se detiene y eso
sería aún peor si los chinos dejarán
este ciclo así que eeuu está encadenado
a este círculo perverso en donde
aparentemente los chinos están
beneficiando totalmente pero que tienen
que seguir acumulando estos bienes por
siempre ya que si dejan de hacerlo el
valor de éstos se desplomara y aunque
los eeuu están perdiendo su base
manufacturera con esto es a su vez están
manteniendo bajas las tasas de interés
lo cual les agradará mucho si es que
ustedes son políticos por lo que harán
que superficialmente el ambiente se vea
positivo hasta aquí dejo el tema por hoy
los invito a que reflexionen en esto y
más adelante analizaremos a dónde nos
lleva esta situación